hello welcome back to the wonderful
beautiful YouTube gaming stage right
here at PAX Prime 2015 I'm your host
Daniel Dwyer delighted to be joined by
Colin Corbo the colossal order how you
doing good good yeah the grapes
early morning it's a it's a long the
start of a long three days of playing
video games one of the games I have
loved playing over the past couple
months is at City skylines you guys
phenomenal success with this game were
you guys surprised at all and we kind of
like yeah I do haven't we we were kind
of expecting the game to sell about as
much as our previous games which is a
lot less than what skyline said and kind
of immediately when the game launched we
at the office we were just looking at
the charts and going like how can this
be yeah because you were no strangers to
making like these types of games yeah
why do you think skylines was the one
that sort of broke through well the
previous games are kind of a niche games
only for small and audience because not
that many people think that public
transportation is interesting they do
you know yeah they do now yes they
should people making you're saying
before he went like making mods for
improved trash disposal yeah it's it's
like all kinds of stuff
I always amazed how how creative and how
excited people are of the game just that
someone actually takes the time and
effort to make a new AI for the garbage
toxin and other people enjoy it they
love it and they comment the mod and
share it done it works so you've got
millions of people playing City skylines
you've got people making mods you got
people making levels and you've now
decided to put out well while ago you
announced an expansion pack paid
expansion pack so what's in it for
people and we're buying it and then
what's the because you've got a free
element to it as well yeah biggest um
one of the things that we only wanted to
do for skylines
was the day and night cycle that's now
the main focus of the first expansion
after dark but we are a team of 14
people so we couldn't actually make
all of this stuff for the gallery yes
Wow so so not all of this stuff could be
in the indeed game when we launched it
so now we are kind of doing all the
stuff that we wanted to make and and all
the stuff that the one fans are really
asking to be added to the game so people
will be getting the day and night cycle
for free so all of the players who have
the game they will just instantly get
the download once it's coming out next
month actually and if they choose they
can kind of go for the paid expansion
that offers a bit more depth into the
day and night so nearly general
specialization so you can have all the
nightclubs and casinos and all of this
stuff that has the neon lights and looks
like they call in the 9th so what was
the idea behind giving away the sort of
the the base day night mechanics to
everyone who played the game each other
like fostering that community we really
felt that it must be a point of the base
game because it's it's something that
really feeling this the city is alive
and it it just it feels like it's such
an essential part of the game that we
wanted everyone to have it and then so
for those sort of specific stuff that
happens at night's line that's in the
paid expansion why do you say you've got
you say you mentioned my club stuff like
that is there gonna be like daytime
activities that only happen like when
people go to the beach in the night well
we kind of did it so that the traffic
kind of dies down a bit during the night
so it's less intense most of the
citizens are staying at home if they
don't have any legend locations to go to
oh wow
so kind of the way the city is acting it
changes during the night and day and
point of if you if the players don't
want to get the paid expansion they can
absolutely play the game with just the
free update and it works just like a
cheat but if they want to get kind of
deeper into the nighttime activities
then they can go for the paid expansion
that's cool so though the ad zombie
parts of the city presumably that'll be
like the like hotspots yeah nightlife
centers and and the player can really
choose where they want to actually place
these in the cities
it's it's kind of it offers much more
possibilities of creating the cities
that actually look like real cities
annually control over what happens and
will and even when what are the main
differences between how the cities and
city skylines act during the daytime as
opposed to the nighttime is there less
traffic is there yeah well the traffic
is the biggest thing because it's it's
kind of intense during the daytime and
we only wanted to make it a bit easier
for the players to handle the traffic so
now that during the night it kind of is
quieter they can choose for example to
have all of the some of the city
services working only at night oh it's
genius
yeah like if I want my garbage trucks
you only go out at night instead of
getting stuck in the traffic jams during
the day I can absolutely do it I was
literally just thinking that because my
garbage guy comes at 6:00 in the morning
yeah wakes my ass up every Friday
morning nightmare and that's cool so
yeah in a weird way what you've created
is a also like a sort of a time of the
day where you can sort of view your city
in in a more like safe state because
you're not it's it's kind of to enjoy
and quiet times and just that if the
player wants to adjust generals or
something they can do it by the
nighttime when there's less traffic so
all in all kind of these phases of
activity so they can choose when stuff
happens and and have more control and
have a different looking city in the
night time so you're like Leeds designer
in this project it must be difficult
when you're looking at say the modern
community and all the stuff that they're
making to try and pick what you guys
want to do right because yeah so much of
that they're doing as well right yeah we
we are kind of our philosophy is that we
will be doing the same stuff as the
motors because it's just plain
impossible so you have what 50,000 mods
go through all of those and never make
anything like it yeah so we will be
doing the same kind of stuff but of
course never just taking a more than
putting it in the game so kind of being
inspired by the mods and seeing how how
we could do these things better and from
a design point of view it's generally
it's awesome that I actually have this
just the statistics of what most people
use oh really because once you publish a
game it's really hard to know what is
the main thing that people are actually
missing yeah like before you had this
modding and Steam Workshop or anything
that you could easily see that this is
the most downloaded one well this is
what's missing that's incredible so what
was in there was it stuff like the
day/night cycle or yeah well the day and
night cycle has been something that the
game did internally support so some of
the models have done their way of day
and night cycle but it was something
that couldn't be done normally well with
the with the vanilla game so we only
wanted to give them the tools to kind of
create different kinds of there is a
nice right and this is kind of I'm
expecting you see the motor generally
come up with different kind of links to
the cycle so someone might have a
four-member night see this would have a
really short days and nights so what
what kind of things they come up with
yeah yeah that's excellent like some
sort of like Alaskan town yeah it's like
nighttime for oh yeah and that's that's
incredible did you guys like presumably
weren't thinking the city skylines going
to sell this much and be this popular
yeah and had you thought about making
expansions before or is this very much a
reaction to oh my god everyone's playing
this game like we can keep working yeah
well since since the beginning of
development on the game we knew that in
the two years we had to make time to
make the game we couldn't make all of
the stuff we wanted so we were planning
to have some of the larger features
coming later
just like the day and night cycle and it
seems to be working quite nicely because
luckily our publisher and others
Interactive is really kind of of the
same opinion that we have to give this
kind of essential features for free yeah
and this is what we are colossal I
really want to do that's excellent 40
person team as well hmm that's amazing
like it's such work a two year cycle to
get that out yeah well and it also helps
us so that because the community really
understands like when the game came out
and people are complaining that voice it
they're on day and night cycle we could
just tell them that we have 14 people
and they were like oh how many of you
guys are over here at the moment in
packs just me no sir so I need your
first time here yeah knocks is there
anything you're gonna go check out
yourself when you're done being
interviewed by lots of them I do well I
I will go and do lots of more interviews
but I'm only looking forward to just
seeing the city and seeing the
convention because it's it's awesome
yeah it's good fun when is there after
that gonna be available I know you've a
new gameplay trailer to just welcome
there as well at the end of September
so a joint list someone right around the
corner yeah oh I hope your jet lag is
worn off back in Finland for the time
yeah by that time maybe yeah kinda thank
you so much pleasure to meet you better
luck at with the rest of the game I look
forward to doing that and seeing what
else do you guys come up with that going
forward over the next couple years
thank you so much hi I'm thank you guys
for watching and we've got a bunch more
stuff coming up at Clifford's in skis
and coming pretty soon with lawbreakers
we're gonna have Randy Pitchford on to
talk about and what I'm gonna ask him
about the Borderlands movie but he's
here to talk about bow born as well of
course playable here and loads more over
the course of the day so stay tuned to
our stage here at YouTube gaming and
we'll be back real soon